das geht ja es geht ab ich bin dave ich
möchte heute gerne mit euch heide lippen
ich hab selber nie ausprobiert ist aber
eine möglichkeit aus diesem langweiligen
studienleistung custom zu machen
jeglicher farbkombination die man will
ist so einfach dass ich sie ganz gerne
nachmachen
viel spaß damit die einzigen dinge die
er dafür benötigt sind zum einen die
schule ein während bei mir sind es jetzt
eher vertrauen weil daran schön viel
platz und man die farbe hinten überhaupt
erst frühjahr für oder graffiti fahren
muss auch klar natürlich in den farben
in denen ihr die haben wollt ich habe
jetzt hier ein paar verschiedene geholt
wir noch lila und mal schauen welche
farbkombination wieder im endeffekt
machen sie ist so laut alter sollten weg
ist und jemand gekauft um die ränder
abzukleben wo eben keine farbe hin soll
lieber in streichen die immer wenn man
ihnen was mit farbigen windräder
zitronen denn wenn ihr neue schuhe
einführen wollten diesen film aus der
fabrik drauf 9
neuheit film richtig genau nicht okay
dann braucht ihr noch eine große fest
damit hier so eine box oder einmal teams
auch ich zeig euch gleich wofür das
eingehen aber das ist genau so
essenziell die anderen kommen eben noch
so kleine scheite dazu gesagt leber und
handschuhe und steht an allererster ist
das für die schüler ausgehen weil die
worden - mit firmen und mit aceton eben
diesen film arbeiten damit die
fabelhaften bringt genau das tun wir
jetzt
[Musik]
nachdem man die schuhe wenn ihr fertig
seid die schuhe sauber zu machen bis ich
mich entscheiden welche teile überhaupt
von ihm zu einfach
wir haben uns dafür entschieden genau
diesen teil um diesen teil der
einzufärben so dass eben das wunsch das
ding hier im hintergrund und das hier
vorne alles clean bleibt und wir eben
nur dass das und auf der anderen seite
dasselbe taschen und das wird
hoffentlich leistung ganz gut ich würde
mich über jegliche reaktion auf das
video freuen wenn ihr bock habt andere
schuhe zu sehen oder leute mit denen ich
das machen deutschland mit dass in die
kommentare und dann schauen wir was wir
daraus machen kann
ansonsten könnt ihr auch abstimmen ich
hab schon so 23 schuhe im kopf und
farbkombination aber schon jetzt gerne
als heute
[Musik]
wir sind endlich fertig für zwei stunden
gebraucht also hätten das alleinige
macht wir als vier stunden gewesen
bügelte anstrengend und jetzt sind wir
halt die farben zu machen was mit mega
leisten schlussendlich haben wir uns für
diese vier fahrer menschen ja selber
keine ahnung nichts im endeffekt
aussieht ist aber ich würde sagen
gestalten einfach und schauen was dabei
rumkommt
[Musik]
walter nein ich bin mega zufrieden ich
bin so gespannt wie das ok zweiter
schuhe ich bin nicht mehr aufbringen als
beim ersten mal sehen dies klar
[Musik]
nein hier ist ein bisschen zu viel aber
der hier sieht mega gut aus hammer ich
bin so gespannt wie die aussehen wenn
die getrocknet sind ich kann es halt 0 1
schätzt sie sehr vielversprechend aus
ja bis hierhin voller erfolg wir sehen
morgen ob es dann wirklich komplett
geklappt hat also bis gleich hallo sowie
rund zwölf stunden warte die schuhe sind
trocken wir können endlich die
abgeklebten stellen abnehmen ist das
fertige resultat
[Musik]
wir wollen euch den schuh jetzt zeigen
jetzt nicht mehr geleistet wurden haben
wir noch eine schippe drauf damit die
farbe genau an der stelle bleibt wo wir
die nachholen nicht dass man irgendwo
gegen kommt und die farbe weg weg
[Musik]
wir haben den karton jetzt genau in dem
selben design auch noch einmal geheilt
wird ist ganz einfach aus dem grund dass
wenn wir jetzt mehrere schule machen
sollten wie die irgendwie im karton noch
auseinander halten müssen wenn wir die
stapel und wenn das so wirklich im
endeffekt funktioniert ist es glaube ich
auch noch mal eine coole sache
oder sieht echt mega heiß auf das ist im
endeffekt der fertige suchen ihr seht
euch hier nochmal ein paar aufnahmen
davon es hat auf jeden fall megawatt
gemacht den schuh zu machen ich bin
super zufrieden mit dem ergebnis auch
wenn das jetzt nicht eine
farbkombination ist die ich
wahrscheinlich selber tragen würde
wenn ihr aber lust habt was ich das mal
mit anderen leuten zusammen machen oder
mit anderen schulen dann schreibt mir
das auf jeden fall in die kommentare und
wir sehen was wir machen kann so dass
mit einem ersten video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen das hat michael bock
gemacht ich hoffe die quali stimmt alles
perfekt ich freue mich über jegliche
reaktion checkt man dienstag wenn ihr
lust darauf habt und das war's
eigentlich
[Musik]